можна сказати негативно michelin
порядні люди на я думаю що загашвіли
Після параметрів ж українця можуть не
доросла до того й швидко сидить їх за ідеєю
хто його знає мені подобався щось робить
сам означає ще й маціону у достатку
і якого боку видно
кримів до серйозного видно ось досвіду
проти ok with б у нього обожнювання
займалися займайся проти корупції ну
ідеальністю чи треба
провалилася а це точно є і вже її
друзі з так знаємо обходяться її відкритим
текстом називається ж
вже йому час теж подати заявку до йти
спокійно самому в цій конструкції
сподіваємося, що не провалилася цього рибу
не vida заз одному хармана інший
переставляєте з корупція затримається їх
баланс hd з корупцією ми ще не довгі
поборемо тому що зверху треба починати
міні зайти та боротьбу з корупцією за
разом свої руки народу чиновники з
чоловіку цілої кімнати